>> Well, good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to another amazing day at Google.
Today is particularly amazing
since we have Jake here
for a Musicians@Google performance.
It's our pleasure to introduce
Jake Shimabukuro to be here at Google
to share his love for life,
his love for the ukulele,
and his love for traditional Hawaiian culture.
With a very "Google-y" mantra of peace,
love and ukulele,
Jake has taken ukulele to new
heights throughout the world,
from his beloved rendition of
"While My Guitar Gently Weeps, "
which really was my first
introduction to his work,
to his self-composed virtuosic Toastman
and everything else that's on his recorded works.
He's an ambassador of Hawaiian
culture.
He's actually shared his love for the ukulele
with everyone from the Queen of England
to legions of Parrot Heads, such as myself
as a member of the Coral Reefer Band,
and that's not to mention his big role at YouTube
where he has popularized the ukulele.
And also, you know, just really touched
the lives of millions of people
that have seen his YouTube videos.
He has an enthusiasm for life
and music that is really unparalleled
and that's why we're particularly honored
to have him here at Google today.
So he'll be speaking to us today about his life,
his work, and his music.
And as he says,
music is good medicine.
So ladies and gentlemen,
Mr. Jake Shimabukuro.
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you, Cliff.
Well, thank you so much.
You know, as I said earlier,
I'm just ecstatic to be here today.
This is really great.
Just to give you a little bit of background,
you know, myself, I was born
and raised in Honolulu, Hawaii.
And I started playing the ukulele
when I was four years old.
And my mom played and so
she was my first teacher.
And from the moment that
she first put it in my hands,
I mean, I immediately fell in love
with this instrument.
You know, just something about
the sound of it.
You know, because of the high range
of the instrument,
you know, it's -- it always kind of --
it's very similar to like a child's voice,
you know, and I think that this instrument
kind of makes people feel like,
feel like a kid again.
It's just one of those things,
and it's a beautiful, beautiful thing.
And I'm always, you know,
one of the things that
I truly believe is that, you know,
the ukulele is really the instrumen of peace
because if everyone played the ukulele
I think this world would be a happier place.
So I hope to share some of
my happiness with you today.
So I'm going to start off with a little song here.
This is a tune called "143."
It's a new tune that I just --
I just composed.
And I thought it would be
appropriate to kind of open this up
because I remember when I was --
when I was in school,
you know, we didn't have cell phones
or the Internet or anything like that.
You know, it was just -- if you were cool,
you had a pager, you know?
[Laughter]
And so there was no text messaging back then.
So I remember we would have these numeric codes
and 1-4-3 was the numeric code
for "I love you"
and so if you had your girlfriend or your
boyfriend or whatever you would text them
or send them the page 1-4-3,
so this is a song about that.
And it goes something like this:
♪ [Playing ukulele]
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you very much.
So, when I first started playing the ukulele,
growing up in Hawaii,
it was a lot of traditional
Hawaiian music,
so I started out playing things
like
♪ [Strumming traditional Hawaiian Chords]
this is what we all start out playing.
But with three chords,
with those simple three chords,
you can play over 300 traditional Hawaiian tunes.
So it kept me busy for a long time.
But, of course, then when I was a teenager,
you know, I started listening
to different styles of music
and then those three chords became things like
♪ [Strumming rock chords]
and back then I thought,
"Oh, this is so cool."
I was like, wow, I can listen
to all different kinds of,
you know, instruments and try to
mimic like guitar players
and pianists and horn players
and all those things.
And I could find these melodies
and try to play them on the ukulele.
So I started, you know,
experimenting with different styles.
And this next song was kind of
what happened
when I stumbled on to
Carlos Montoya record, you know,
who was a master Flamenco guitar player.
So here is a Flamenco ukulele piece for you.
And this is an original composition
entitled "Let's Dance."
And it goes something like this:
♪ [Playing ukulele]
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you very much.
Thank you,
song entitled "Let's Dance."
[Applause]
So this next tune that I like
to perform is a song
about growing up in Hawaii and being a kid.
And one of my favorite --
one of my favorite drinks as a child was
a good old Shirley Temple, you know.
And I'd drink, like,
I don't know like five or six of these.
I'd always be -- I'd always have that.
There's a lot of sugar in a Shirley Temple.
I was one of those, you know,
and I'd drive my parents crazy sometimes.
But this is a song about being a kid and
drinking one too many Shirley Temples.
And it's a song I like to call
"Me and Shirley T."
And it goes something like this:
♪ [Playing ukulele]
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[Applause]
You know, I truly believe that music
is one of the things that can really,
you know, can really help to,
you know, can help people in so many ways.
There's --
you know, music is all about
communicating just pure emotion.
And that's one of the reasons I really
enjoy performing is because,
you know, you connect with people
on a level that,
you know, I think words can never --
will never be able to do.
And so this is actually, um,
a song that I --
that I wrote a few years ago.
It was for a friend of my mine
whose grandmother was very ill.
She was in the hospital.
And while she was in the hospital,
she was under a lot of medication.
And she would have these hallucinations
of blue roses on the ceiling above her bed.
And at night she'd see the
petals fall on top of her.
And when she shared this with me, you know,
I thought it was such a beautiful vision
and it inspired me to write this next piece.
This is a song,
a song I call "Blue Roses Falling."
♪ [Playing ukulele]
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you very much.
This next song that I like to perform
is actually, um,
was my attempt at attacking
a song that was completely
composed to --
for a certain instrument.
And this is a Japanese folk tune
that is usually --
well, it was normally played on the
koto,
which is a 13-stringed instrument that sits on
the floor and you play it with these finger picks.
And it has the most incredible sound,
you know.
And I remember hearing this instrument
while I was in Japan
and I was just completely blown away.
It just took me to another place, you know.
So when I got--
when I went back home to Hawaii,
I wanted to--
I remember just that haunting sound
was just stuck in my head
and I wanted to figure out a way to
express that through my instrument.
And so this is a song entitled
"Sakura Sakura, "
it's about the annual cherry blossom
season in Japan.
And this is my attempt at --
well this was my attempt at transforming
my little 4-string Hawaiian ukulele
into a 13-string Japanese koto.
♪ [Playing ukulele]
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you.
"Sakura Sakura."
This next tune, um, is a song.
You know, a few years ago
my dad told me, he said,
"You write all these songs but how come
you never wrote a song for me, you know?"
And I was, oh,
okay.
So, so I wrote this song for my dad about a --
about almost two years ago.
But it was -- it's a song,
cause I remember
when I was a kid and my dad would --
he had this green pickup truck
and for some reason,
he was always low on gasoline,
you know.
So as soon as we got in his truck the first
stop was always the nearest gas station.
And I remember when we would pull in,
the attendant would come to the car
and my dad would say, "$5 unleaded."
You know, and I just thought oh,
that's so cool, you know.
So this song is about those times
when we'd go to the gas station
and I wrote the piece --
I wrote this song in three parts.
The first part reflects all the emotions
that you feel
when you're driving around
on a full tank of gasoline.
So it's very bouncy, upbeat, and happy.
And the second part is everything that --
is everything you feel
when that fuel light starts to flash.
The music changes a bit,
you get a little stressed out and worried
looking for that nearest gas station.
And then the third part is when you, um,
you actually find the gas station.
And you pull in and then you stop, right?
You stop and then you fill up your gas tank.
And you know goo, goo, goo...
and then it gets it happy again, right?
And you're off and driving away.
So this is the tune I call "$5 Unleaded."
And it goes something like this:
♪ [Playing ukulele]
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you very much.
You know, it's been really amazing
over the last few years now.
I've been having incredible
opportunities to play for all --
you know, to play all over the world.
And you know in the last few years now,
I've been able to travel to places
like Japan and Australia,
Canada, Singapore,
Saipan, Guam.
And last year I actually started --
it was my first time touring Europe
and we did --
we did like Sweden, Finland, France.
And about in a couple weeks,
I'm going to do another Europe tour.
And I'll be going to places like Russia,
the Netherlands, Poland.
I never ever would have thought
that this little four-string instrument
when I was at home practicing.
♪ [Strumming traditional Hawaiian chords]
I don't think my parents ever thought,
that keep practicing, boy,
you're going to go to Russia one
of these days and play -- [Laughter] --
and travel the world.
So, um,
but this next tune is, um,
is a song that was inspired by one of my --
one of my heroes, you know.
And that's another thing, you know,
playing the ukulele,
I've been able to collaborate with a lot
of musicians that I grew up listening to.
People that have inspired me,
you know, people like --
like Cliff was saying,
Jimmy Buffet and the Coral Reefer Band,
and I would record with people like
Yo-Yo Ma,
Ziggy Marley.
This -- Bette Midler.
It's been really insane.
And, um,
this next song was inspired by another
one of my heroes, the great BŽla Fleck,
whom I did a tour with about three years ago
with BŽla Fleck and the Flecktones.
And we did a bunch of these bluegrass festivals.
It was just incredible.
I was so inspired by the music
and it kind of motivated me
to write this next song.
This is kind of a bluegrass ukulele piece
that was partly inspired
by the Orange Blossom Special.
This is a song I call "Orange World."
♪ [Playing ukulele]
[Applause]
Jake Shimabukuro: Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Well, you know, at this time I really
want to thank all of you very, very much
because, um,
you know, I would not be here today
if it weren't for --
if it weren't for Google and YouTube.
And, you know, you have --
it's really been amazing, you know,
for artists like myself or anyone
that has something to share
with the rest of the world now
because they have access to you.
I mean just, you know,
right now I'm just a click away
from anyone, you know.
If they want to learn more about what I do,
you know, and it's so great.
And one of the things that, um,
that I really, really, um--
that's really important to me is
through music and through everything
that I do with ukulele,
you know, I talked about the instrument
of peace and all of that.
And I really believe in that.
I really believe that music
brings so much joy to people.
And -- and I really take it upon myself because,
you know, like other artists,
you know,
because of what you do,
allowing people like myself to share
what we do with the --
with people all over the world, you know,
I feel a great responsibility
that we share good things.
We use -- we use Google and we use
YouTube as a way to promote
positive energy and a way to
promote positive thinking, you know.
And for me growing up with a ukulele,
you know,
this is just -- it's like the perfect tool.
Anyone can learn this instrument.
It's the easiest thing to do,
I mean, seriously.
I know that I was told there are
a lot of people here at Google
that actually play the ukulele.
So I was pretty excited,
you know, to hear about that.
Because it truly is, it's,
you know, there's a really great
resurgence in this instrument.
And if you look on -- you know,
I'm sure all of you are aware,
you just go on Google or YouTube
and you would just find all these young kids
like just shredding on ukulele
and doing all these great things, you know.
People are trading in their
guitars for ukuleles now.
And I just think that's fantastic.
And it's the perfect combination
because here you have
what you do which is --
you know, so on --
in the digital age and,
this time of advanced technology,
you guys are so much on this end of the spectrum,
you know, just leading the way.
And the ukulele is kind of like
on the complete opposite of the
spectrum,
you know,
it's kind of like -- it's the
most simple of all instruments.
And it's the most humble and
it's so -- I don't know.
It's just there's something
really magical about it.
It's the only instrument that you can just mention
the name to someone and they'll smile.
Like sometimes I travel and I'll be sitting
at the airport with my case
and someone will come up to me,
hey, what's in the case and they're expecting me to say violin or something
but I'll be like "Oh no, it's a ukulele."
And they would be like
"Oh, it's a ukulele?
Wow, you play the u-ka-lay-lee"?
You know,
but what other instrument would
provoke that, right?
And so,
there's something really special
and magical about it
and that's why, you know,
I'm so, I'm so happy to be here.
If it weren't for what you do and what you,
you know, provide for the world,
you know, I wouldn't be here today
and I wouldn't be able to travel
and do all these --
continue doing my passion.
So I really, really appreciate, you know,
your gift to me.
Thank you very, very much.
Cliff: As is our tradition here
at the Musicians@Google project,
we do leave some time
for questions and answers.
So does anyone have any
questions for Jake right now?
>> Hi Jake, thank you.
That was outstanding.
How do you structure your
practice time when you're --
I imagine you're kind of mature
in your craft now,
but how is that -- how is your practice
time different than it was growing up?
And then how -- how do you
structure like songwriting
versus skill maintenance, et cetera,
while you're practicing?
Jake Shimabukuro: Yeah, well, when I was--
when I was growing up, you know,
I never--
it was really no such thing as,
you know, oh, you better practice your ukulele,
you better practice ukulele.
Growing up, you know, people
are always you always hear like--
I got to practice piano.
I got to practice violin.
That's -- those were considered
serious instruments
where you need to spend time practicing.
But the ukulele was definitely
not one of those instruments.
I mean it was, you know,
it was like if you play the ukulele,
it was just more of a fun thing.
It was like playing video games
or something.
That's -- that's how I looked at it.
And a lot of times my parents would
have to take the instrument away from me
so that I would eat dinner or I would,
you know,
go do my homework
or clean my room.
Because they -- I never wanted to --
I could never put it down, really.
So I never thought of it as practice.
To me, growing up it was never,
oh, I better put in my three hours
of ukulele practice or four hours
or whatever it was.
It was just every time would
I come home from school,
I would pick it up and I would play,
do some homework and pick it up
and play, after I shower,
pick it up and play.
You know, I just absolutely loved it.
So it was -- now looking back,
I realize that that was --
that's I was so passionate
about that instrument.
And I never wanted to play anything else.
Most people start out with the ukulele
but after that,
they want to move on to the guitar
or another instrument
where they can -- they can play
different styles of music.
But the ukulele for some reason,
I just fell in love with it.
And I fell in love with the limitations
of the instrument
because I never saw the limitations
as something that would hold me back.
I always -- I always believe that,
you know,
the -- the instrument is what it is.
It's -- it's beautiful just the way it is.
And I think it's, it's, you know,
is the people who pick it up,
we're the ones that put
limitations on the instrument.
The instruments aren't limited
by themselves
and a lot of times we just have to look
to ourselves to use your imaginations
and expand on other ways.
And the way that I see the ukulele is because
you know it has such a small range
and it's only four strings,
I find a lot of power in that, you know,
because then it challenges me to--
to really, um,
to really expand on the other,
the other aspects of music.
You know, if you play the piano,
there's so many notes that you can pretty
much cover whatever you want to cover.
But it's like the way I like to think of it is,
you know, you have all your senses
but like,
for example, like someone who is blind,
someone who is visually impaired,
you know, their sense of hearing,
their sense of touch, smell,
becomes so incredible because
they're not relying on their vision anymore.
So it's like with the ukulele
I can't rely on its range
because it doesn't have the kind
of range that --
that a piano or any other instrument
would have.
So in that sense,
now I have to take advantage of
the other aspects of music:
Tone color, timbre,
you know, dynamics.
You know, all these rhythmic things,
chord voicings and expanding on
harmonies and things like that.
So for me a lot of the practice
that I would put into
wasn't just so much sitting
with the instrument and playing,
but was just kind of
experiencing life, you know,
just kind of going out and seeing things and --
and trying different things, you know.
All of that, that's --
whenever I pick up the ukulele,
that's what I'm playing.
That's what I'm doing.
And when I'm composing songs,
a lot of times I'll just focus
on a specific moment in my life
and how I felt and then I try to --
I try to, um, you know, express
that through the ukulele.
So for me, practice time is 24 hours a day.
It's when I'm sleeping.
It's when I'm having lunch.
It's, you know, visits like these,
surrounding myself with --
in a room full of geniuses
and just being inspired.
That's really what it's all about.
And I think for me the, you know, as far as
like practicing all the technical stuff,
what I do instead of just
sitting in front of the --
instead of just sitting in my room and
practicing one technique over and over
what I do -- because that's --
that's meaningless.
If you just sit there and you
practice right-hand tapping,
you just -- over and over,
then it's like so what?
Okay, you can do that,
but what I would do is
I would take one technique
and I would just write a song
around that one technique.
So that way I'm not just practicing
the technique,
but by practicing a song and playing the song,
you know, essentially I'm mastering
that one technique.
So if I'm playing a Flamenco
piece and I'm doing these things,
these Flamenco strums, and all that,
I won't do that in any other song,
I'll keep it specific for that song.
So that becomes my song.
You know, if I'm doing a tapping tune
that becomes that song.
Or if I'm doing a crazy banjo-like
bluegrass-y thing
that just becomes for that song,
all the techniques that I use is
just for that song.
So -- and I think that that
really helped me to focus on --
that really helped me to keep each song
a little bit unique.
Because with instrumental music,
it's so difficult.
They all pretty much sound the same,
you know, after awhile and especially
with the ukulele my goal was
always to make every, every song sound different.
Because I didn't have a vocalist,
I'm a horrible singer,
so that's why I would have to do
a lot of instrumental music.
Thank you.
>> Hello.
First of all, I think you're God's
gift to music, at least to me.
[Applause]
And I just had a couple of
questions about -- did you ever
get formal training in music?
Just that your form and your melodies
sound so intricate,
did you ever go to formal music school?
And do you ever experiment with
your instrument as with effects
and all those fancy things?
Thank you.
Jake Shimabukuro: Yeah, well,
thank you very much first of all.
Thank you.
You know, I started out just playing by ear and just having fun with the
ukulele.
And then later on when I was a teenager,
someone turned me on to music theory,
and I was like music theory,
what is that?
And then, that's when I just started,
you know, I started buying these books
and just reading about notes
and reading about like when you see
like a C7 chord -- what is the 7?
What does the 7 mean?
Why do we have these numbers in chords?
So then I got turned on to music theory
and then I became really obsessed with it.
I started -- it was my --
see normally, when people --
I think when most students of music
begin their journey,
they start off reading music, right?
They start off reading music,
they learn all the proper way to
hold their instruments,
they learn -- traditionally,
there is a sequence of things that
you learn to get to where you want to,
where you want to do.
But the interesting thing I
think for me,
is starting with the ukulele,
I really started backwards.
I really started --
when I first started playing,
people would tell me okay,
put your fingers here and strum that.
Now, the next chord,
put your finger here and just do
this and I would be like okay.
And it was fun.
I didn't -- I didn't know anything about notes.
I didn't know anything about rhythms
or anything like that.
It was just, okay, this sound and this sound
and getting familiar with what --
you know, it's like speaking,
when you talk.
You're not so worried about the words that
you're using when you're learning to speak.
Just whatever comes out,
when babies talk they make all
kinds of weird sounds,
but that's how they learn.
And that's kind of how I learned
to play music.
I had absolutely no idea what I was playing,
and I couldn't make any sense of
it but I knew that I liked the sound.
It was like, okay.
And then I'd hear other people play
and it would be like,
okay, let me try and sound like that,
you know.
And that's how we learn when we speak,
we just -- we're just surrounded
by people who speak the language
that we want to learn.
And then we just start, we're hearing it
all the time and we try to mimic
and that's--
that's how I started playing the ukulele.
And then later on,
once I got familiar with--
with hearing other musicians play something,
and then I could --
I was like I know that sound.
And I could just play it,
even though I don't know what
I'm doing or what they're doing,
I could mimic them and that's kind of like
how we learn how to talk, right?
Then after that, once I developed my ear,
then it kind of went --
then I started getting into like,
okay, there's a way that you can notate
this and you can actually write music.
And I was like, what is that?
And then I started learning about notes.
Then I started learning about theory.
You know, in college,
I took some -- some music theory
courses.
I took classes in composition
and all these things that I've been doing
when I was kid made sense.
I was like, oh, I see.
Oh, that's what I'm doing. Okay.
And so it was -- it was just --
it was a different kind of feeling,
I think for me.
I had a different experience, you know,
because I was -- I was kind of
already doing some of this stuff.
And then for a professor to sit
there and tell me okay, this is what --
this is what you're doing.
And I would be like oh, okay.
Now I understand.
And because I was already doing it,
you know, it's kind of weird
because even like improvising,
my whole life basically I was improvising.
But then going from there to how
learning how to read music and
to sit in front of a sheet and
then learn how to play, you know,
what I'm told to play
became a totally different experience.
And then learning it that way,
it was -- I think it really helped me
to become more of a natural,
instinctive player.
So if I'm in a situation and I'm playing with
a string quartet or if I'm playing, you know,
with a jazz trio or a rock band
or a blues band whatever it is,
I could just sit there and listen
and figure out what to do.
And with the ukulele it's a little tricky
because there aren't, you know,
you don't -- it's not like you can --
if you play the trumpet,
you can go and listen to a Miles Davis
record and learn how to play jazz.
But with the ukulele,
it's like, if you want to learn
how to play Flamenco ukulele,
you're not really going to able to find
a Flamenco player and listen to them,
you just have to, you just have
to create your own path, you know.
And I think for me, that was --
that was key, you know,
is by learning the way that I did,
starting out the way that I did.
I had no rules.
There were no boundaries,
nothing told me that you have to do this
way you have to do that way, you know.
But I was just free to do whatever
I wanted and experiment with anything.
And going to the effects and all that,
I actually went through a whole period
of playing through Marshall Stacks
and wa wa pedals and all of that,
you know.
And it's funny because you go through
that whole phase,
you know, I went through a phase
where I had a pedal board
that had like 13 different effect pedals on
there.
You know, everything from like see-quas,
to delays,
and you know all these crazy echoes and phasers
and flangers and all of that, you know.
And then, and then about four years ago,
four or five years ago,
I just kind of,
I put that aside and I --
and I went back to just the pure basic
acoustic sound of the instrument
because I realized that that's where --
that's where the instrument's strength
lies in its simplicity.
And so ever since then, yeah,
I've just --
I've just gone back to just the pure
sound of the instrument.
>> So you have videos on YouTube
that have over a million views.
Were you initially aware of that?
And how has that contributed to your success?
Jake Shimabukuro: Well, you know, the video of
"While My Guitar Gently Weeps" in Central Park,
that video, I think got put up on YouTube
five years ago
so it was when YouTube just kind of started,
so at the time,
I'll be honest, at the time I didn't know what YouTube was.
But there was, but this was five years ago, right?
So you know, now everybody knows what it is.
But I was getting e-mails from friends
because I had a lot of friends that were up here
on the mainland in college and stuff
and they'd e-mail me and they'd be like,
"hey, man there's like this crazy video
of you like going around our campus.
Did you know about this?"
And I was no -- I was just
sitting at home and you know,
really doing just surfing and stuff.
But the whole time while I was in Hawaii
there was this little viral video
that was going around
and then I started getting --
I was getting contacted
by people all over the world.
People saying, oh my gosh,
I just saw this video of you playing
in Central Park and I love the ukulele.
Do you have --
do you have any music or CDs or --
I want to get your stuff or can you come
and you know play in our city?
And all this kind of thing.
It was just -- growing up in Hawaii,
you know, I started out playing in coffee shops
and the coffee shops I started playing in,
you know, you couldn't hold more than
four or five people.
That was a full house.
So, I mean, it really --
it really I mean I was just blown away.
I didn't know what to think of it.
I couldn't wrap my head around it.
I still can't.
I still can't because, you know,
I mean to this day,
I still get people that come to
the shows and they say that,
you know, oh, I discovered you
through YouTube.
I discovered you through YouTube.
Nine out of ten people will tell me that.
And it's really been amazing.
And I feel so blessed, you know,
because of that.
And you know, I guess it's really changed.
It's changed the way that people
hear music and discover artists now.
You know for -- even for me,
I spend hours and hours on YouTube,
you know, looking up --
like, for example,
if I just want to --
if I want to, you know,
get a guitar lesson from Jimmy Bruno,
I just type in his name and bam!
You know, I can learn all of his licks
and all of his guitar methods.
It's insane.
Anytime that I need a little jolt of inspiration,
you know, I'll go pull up some YouTube
video of one of my favorite artists,
you know, and that's something
that you could never do before.
When I growing up learning music
and everything was like cassette tapes
or then CDs just you came out
and I was like okay, this is great.
I would have to actually have to sit with
the cassette tape, if I wanted to learn a song,
I'd have to sit there rewind it
over and over and listen stop it,
rewind, listen again,
oh, stop, rewind.
I'd have to do that over and over
and I couldn't even --
and still that's just using my ears.
I could not visually see what
was happening.
You know, but now, these young kids now
they learn so fast.
There's all these virtuosos now
because they have unlimited access to
any artist that they want of any instrument.
So they can -- they can if
they're interested in ukulele,
they can just type in ukulele,
you know they can Google it or YouTube it
and it will come up all these videos and
they can just sit there from front of their computer
and actually watch someone playing it
for them like right in front of them --
right in front of their eyes.
And they can pause it, learn it,
get the right fingering,
you know, go back and pause it again.
And it's tremendous.
I wish I had that
when I was a kid, you know.
Because I -- I don't know -- I don't know
how that would have changed what I do today.
I don't know, maybe --
I mean,
I really don't know how that's going
to effect these younger musicians.
Because now -- sometimes I do workshops
and the thing that I find with a lot of these students
that come to these workshops is
they want to just--
they don't want to -- they don't have the patience
to learn the fundamentals of music anymore.
It's like they want that immediate.
I want to learn this song.
How do you do this?
Before they even know exactly,
you know, the proper fingering or the proper
right-hand technique of strumming.
They don't want to do that as long as --
they just want to learn the song.
They just want to, oh no, I want to learn
how you played that on --
and that ending on YouTube,
how are you doing that?
All that fast stuff. I mean,
so it's changing the way that people think.
People want that instant gratification now
in music I find that, you know.
So you know, I mean in some ways,
I think in some ways it's good
but in some ways it can be bad too.
So I think that, you know,
even with all the technology and
all that we still have to remember that
okay we have to instill in this kids that
you know sometimes do take work.
Sometimes you have to work hard
to achieve something
and not everything can be
as simple as just being a click away.
You know, like my--
my little nephews and stuff,
they don't even know what a library is.
They're like what's a library?
It's like, what?
They don't -- they have no idea what it is
to go and do research at the public library.
So I mean, so it's different, you know.
I think with certain things
we have to remind,
remind the younger generation
that we have to slow down a little bit.
And we have to appreciate certain things
because there are some things in life
that's not worth just speeding through.
And I think music is one of them,
you know, playing the ukulele,
music is a great way to kind of step away
from that world for a bit
and then kind of connect yourself again with
everything that's happening in the moment.
>> So we have time for one more brief question.
>> Hi. So you're really well-known internationally
for playing like rock and pop and country,
but you got your start --
and I remember hearing you from like
playing contemporary Hawaiian music
and like "Pure Heart" and all of that,
how often do you go back and revisit
that style and compose in that?
Jake Shimabukuro: Oh, well, all the time,
whenever I'm back home in Hawaii,
I mean, all of my buddies
all play traditional Hawaiian music.
And so whenever I'm home --
you know, traditional Hawaiian music will
always be my first love.
That's because what I grew up playing.
And -- which is very strange,
because, you know, if you're a jazz musician and you start playing jazz,
you start learning all these --
you start learning all these complex harmonies
and you learn all these standards.
There's a set of standards that you learn.
All these complicated chord changes
and you start learning how to improvise
over these chord changes.
It's a whole language.
It's the same thing with classical music,
same thing with Flamenco music
or bluegrass or any style of music
that you can think of.
You know, Blues,
but whatever it is,
you know, R&B,
there is kind of --
you know, there's structure.
And but Hawaiian music is kind of --
it's one of the only forms of music
in the world that is so simple.
And the reason it's so simple is because
Hawaiian, traditional Hawaiian music,
you know, when -- traditionally,
there was absolutely no --
there was no harmonic structure.
There was really no melody or anything like that.
That came much, much later.
You know, traditional Hawaiian music
was all about rhythm, drum beats,
this little Hawaiian rhythmic things and chanting.
It was all chanting.
And because -- in Hawaii,
there was no written language,
you know, everything was preserved in song.
So songs were -- were created to just,
you know, I mean, historically,
so that they could -- they could,
so the stories of each generation
could be passed down.
So once -- once instruments like harmonic
instruments like the ukulele or guitar
were introduced into Hawaiian music,
you know, it started out very simple.
Sometimes only two chords
or sometimes just one chord.
Sometimes if you listen to chanting,
like old traditional chanting,
it will only be two notes.
Just -- it would be aaaaah, uuuuh, aaaah
and they'll be chanting all this stuff.
And that's -- that's all it was.
You know, so the music is very, very simple.
It's so simple.
And I think that's -- and I think, you know,
for me starting out with that,
you know, I have a great appreciation.
Like I can sit with a ukulele and just strum
a C chord for an hour and not get bored.
But you try to tell a jazz guy to do that,
he's going to,
I can't just hold a C chord for an hour
and strum that because harmonically,
they just get bored.
They won't -- they can't even hold a C triad,
it's got to be a Major 7 or a Major 9
or they got to add the Sharp 13
or something you know,
they got to change it up because it's not --
it doesn't -- it doesn't stimulate anything
for them. It's not enough.
But I think playing the ukulele,
you learn to appreciate music
in its most simplest form
and then in its most complex form.
And that's a great,
to me there's a great power in that.
You know and I think with --
with playing traditional Hawaiian music
and going back to that for me always
helps me to keep balance.
Whenever I go back home and I'm
playing with my buddies,
and we're just sitting around
the -- the roasted pig,
you know, the big pig on the stick or whatever,
we're just like -- we're just
have a little jam session
and playing all these traditional Hawaiian tunes
that I grew up with really helps to bring me
back to my roots and kind of keeps me,
you know, keeps my mind --
it keeps that window open.
So it's -- it's all about balance, I think.
And that's what I always try to
maintain when in what I do.
Cliff: Awesome. Well, thank you very much Jake.
That was a amazing show.
Thanks again for performing for us.
Jake Shimabukuro: I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much guys.
Thank you very, very much.
Really, really appreciate it. I --
[Applause]
I know how incredibly busy you guys
are I mean you guys are so busy
you guys have your laundry
room here and everything.
And I -- you know,
so I really appreciate your time.
Thank you so much.
Take care and aloha.
We'll see you soon.
Thank you.